It has been very easy to talk to you and
for you seem like a person who I would
have a good like day off with
a viral New York Times article,
featured 36 questions that
could supposedly make any
two people falling in love.
We want it to see what would happen if
we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Audrey.
I'm originally from St Louis,
Missouri and I am so single. And when
was the last time that you did it?
We're in this APP age, so you know,
I'll go on dates all the time.
I Dunno.
But a real relationship has been awhile.
My name is Kelly and I'm from Atlanta.
My relationship status is whatever I want.
So I guess I'm will, I'm saying, oh,
I feel great. I had a great breakfast. Um,
it's beautiful outside and I'm ready
for a blind date. Let's do this.
I'm about to go on the weirdest
date I've ever been on.
Welcome to the weird date.
Oh, hello. Nice to meet you.
Nice to, I already said that. So I'll say
it again. Okay. Let's do the teeth. Okay.
I'm a little bit tasty.
Oh,
it's Kevin meal. So are we going to
do questions? I've already forgot.
Let's do it. If you are going to become
a close friend with your partner,
please share what would be important
for him or her to know. Okay.
This is one that I'm going to say and
everybody's going to hear it and I'm okay
with that.
Okay.
I think everybody who is my good friend
knows and accepts that I'm very gassy.
Okay. Hey, that happens.
Everybody eats, everybody fights
and it happens. It's a human thing.
I do a lot of them.
Your Professional. Yes.
That's what's cool. I need to know. Um,
I lose things constantly and I don't
have a wallet and I misplaced my keys,
my debit card and my license all the
time. Yeah. I have them all here today.
Wow. Yeah. Sorry. Good. It's the gassy.
Oh No. The action. What do you
value most in a friendship? Um,
giggles. Yeah. Yeah. I
just want to giggle. Yes.
It doesn't have to be more complicated
than that. You can make me laugh.
What's laugh?
Yeah.
I want to like almost pee my pants when
I think people from laughter. Yeah.
Not from incontinence. Um,
okay. What do you values?
Um,
just someone who's
chill with being themselves with you.
It's so nice.
Honesty and giggles. Yeah.
Yeah. Those two ingredients,
that's all you need. How do you feel
about your relationship with your mother?
I love her. Yeah. Good. She is awesome.
She's so kind and I wish you lived closer.
Yeah,
I know that feeling. Okay.
I have two moms. My older,
my mom be, she is the kind of
person that everybody loves.
We automatically,
she's like gregarious and like bright.
And then my mom and my
younger one is my birth mom.
And what is her name? If she's, she's
just mom. There's mom and mom. Mom.
Yeah.
She is like a genius.
He's really good at fixing things herself
and she's the kind of person who makes
a lot of sacrifices for
other people, like, you know,
how did they meet with them
on a blind date? Incredible.
Name three things you and your
partner appear to have in common.
Okay. Let's talk about,
look at the striped shirt.
Black Pants.
So Alvin is checked off.
We are in arts in true,
we both would love to relax with
coffee and that's a great one.
That's like a very solid, yeah, yeah,
yeah. All right, next one then.
Oh Lord,
what is true love.
Okay.
My current understanding
of what true love might be,
it's just finding someone you can be
your full self with all the goods and the
bads.
I totally agree.
It's like having an extension of yourself.
You have to live with all of
the good and bads in you. Right.
And when you can like fully accept that
in somebody else and like be supported
by them and support them through
anything, that's true. Laughs.
All right.
Share a personal problem
and ask your partners advice
on how she might handle it.
Okay. Ah, okay.
No problem. And I've got a few. Gosh,
my biggest issue right now,
it's sort of funding the balance
between working a super demanding job.
Also finding time to simultaneously
pursue my own creative projects.
So hard. Finding that balance
is my problem right now.
That's a very hard one. Yeah.
And I'm supposed to give
you advice. Right? I guess,
I don't know. I think you're
doing a very normal struggle,
struggling like that.
It's only going to make you stronger.
Um, okay. Your personal
style problem you took mine,
you can have the same problem and
I can relate the same information.
I feel like it's in the exact same vein.
Okay.
But my personal problem is that I'm
worried that I don't have quite enough
direction in what I'm doing and
I'm worried that I'm floundering.
Sometimes it like crosses my mind that
like maybe I'm not working toward any
goal right now.
That's so common for people pursuing
creative paths in any short.
But in terms of not having enough
direction, I'm sure that you do,
but I think just like finding the thing
that you want to say to the world that
only you could say and sharing
that through your work.
Oh,
how do you do?
I'm working on it myself,
but
you of course have things that are
important to you and sort of putting those
out proudly and whatever artistic
shape that takes and standing by it.
And I know you can do that.
Yeah.
Oh,
thanks.
It's all about I want to see your
work and your performances. Yes,
we will. We can make
this continue. All right.
This might be the final question.
Done.
Oh, what'd you go on a second
date with your partner? Yes. Yeah.
Sounds good.
Already reached this conclusion.
We'll make this other thing.
I want to high five you again,
but it's like we can do
it. Let's do it. Okay.
To good high fives today.
Were you looking at elbow?
I was looking for that.
Good day.
That's a wrap, folks. We
did it. Okay. He guys,
it's Taylor and I'm Julia.
Thank you for watching another episode
of tea for to let us know what your
favorite question or answer
was and for more videos,
you can't get a Kia and also subscribe
to our channel. See you guys later.